e
e e
okay
folks a very very quick reminder though
I've been emailing you about this your
first quiz is on March 3rd which is two
weeks from two days ago so it's Monday
two weeks from now so I put out the
review session the the past quizzes and
the best way to prepare for it is to
actually work through the past quizzes
work through not look at the problem
look at the solution because it'll look
obvious once you look at the solution
try to work through try to get stuck and
unstuck on your own before you look at
the solution right and the first few
quizzes will take you time but as you
you get through you'll two it'll help
you on two things one it'll get your
mechanics nailed down and the second is
you'll get used to the way I write
problems so you're not looking at the
new quiz and saying this looks strange
to me I've never seen anything like this
before so that out of the way I won't
ask you about the project because by now
you know what the question is and by now
you're not even answering so I'll assume
that you have a company you picked a
group and you're all on your way right
so today I want to complete our disc
discussion of equity risk premiums right
so if you think about where we were in
the last session we started by looking
at the equity risk premium for the US
not because we're us Centric but because
this is where the data is richest we
looked at historical risk premiums
Dereck remind me again what the problem
with historical risk premiums is when
you look backwards to get a risk premium
for the
US one is it's too noisy even with a 100
Years of data you get this big standard
error second it's by definition backward
looking and the world has
changed and three it it's lazy You're
Just Looking Backward and say that's
what the world is going to look like in
the future and I suggest an alternative
which is a forward-looking premium again
don't let the words implied and the
mechanics drive you off it's just like a
yield to maturity for stocks that's
basically what we're doing replacing
coupons with dividends and BuyBacks and
then asking question what internal rate
of return would make my so it's
completely model agnostic it just says
this is what you're paying for stocks
this is what you expect to return is you
back out the premum and then towards the
end of the class we talked about what do
we do with the rest of the world whether
we like it or not we have to be aware
and we'll talk about why even if you
picked a US company or european company
you need to know what the equity risk
cream for China is you cannot value a
company without that coming into play
and I started in that process and I gave
you two ways one was to take the default
spread we came up with for a country
remember the default spread we use for
the risk free rate and use that as the
additional country risk premium just add
it on to us premium and then as a second
and slightly more sophisticated if you
can call it that you take the default
sprad and said that's what I would
charge for buying a bond but equities
are riskier how much riskier I looked up
two numbers the standard deviation in
the equity index in the Brazil the baspa
in India the sensex in China the shenzen
and compare to the standard deviation
the Government Bond like an algebra PR
and say if I'm charged in a 2% default
spread for buying the bond and equities
are 1 and a half times more risky I'm
going to charge a 3% at risk PR and you
add that on to the US premium you get so
essentially the US premium is no longer
a US premium it's a mature Market Prem
comes your base from which you build
off at the start of every year starting
I think 1994 95 I've been estimating
these country risk premiums and I didn't
do it for others I I need it for myself
and you're going to see this very
quickly when we start to Value
companies and very quickly using this
approach I ran into a problem the prom
was to get a standard deviation in a
Government Bond I need a Government Bond
and if you remember when we talked about
government bonds to get currencies only
about 30 or 40 governments that issue
government
bonds and most of those government bonds
are not
traded so after about five years of
flailing I basically decided to use kind
of a shortcut
so at the start of 2025 I'll take you
through the process you can see how my
shortcut plays out to start the process
I estimated and implied so this is
January 1st 2025 I want to get Equity
risk BRS for the rest of the world I
started by getting an implied Equity
risk premium for the S&P 500 I showed
you the picture of doing this I took the
index I took the cash flows 4.33% what
does that tell me to the extent that I
trust that number Equity investors in
the US are collectively demanding a
4.33% premium over and above the T bond
rate to invest in
stocks first off I start to take a look
at list of countries and if a country is
mature I give it the same Equity risk
premium as the US and already you can
say your your question is going to be
how do you decide what's mature and what
I don't want to make that judgment the
backlash I would get by putting some
country in the immature column I
couldn't handle so I take a shortcut
my shortcut is if Moody and S&P give you
a AAA rating simplistic I'm going to
assume you're a mature market and I'm
going to give you the same Equity risk
premium as the US you see the logic for
this though why should all mature
markets have roughly the same Equity
risk premium
Rey a played out what will happen if the
US is a mature market and Germany is a
mature Market the premium in the US was
4 . 33% and the premium in Germany was
6% what will investors do they will
let's Arbitrage suggest you could
riskless lock in the you don't even you
just move your money where you get a
higher return so essentially when you
have mature markets you can't be having
wildly Divergent Equity risk premiums so
all AAA rated countries you will see
4.33% if you're not AAA rated then my
work is cut out for me double a single a
whatever it is I look up your rating I
come up with the default spread based on
the rating and remember there are three
ways you can use the Sovereign CDs Mark
the same approaches we used to clean up
the risk free rate I come up with the
default
spread and here's where I cheat once I
get the default spread for your country
I essentially look up two standard
deviations but rather than stay within
each country I look at standard
deviations in two indices one is an
index of emerging market equities that
S&P maintains so if you go to the Excel
spreadsheet that contains these risk
breams you can click and it'll take you
to that index it's been around a long
time it's an index of emerging market
equities I look up that standard
deviation and about 10 years ago maybe 8
years ago I found an ETF that invests
only in Emerging Market government bonds
it's publicly traded there's a standard
deviation that number I take the ratio
of the standard deviation of emerging
market equities to Emerging Market
government bonds that ratio the start
2025 was 1.35 I apply it to every comp
country's default spread it's cheating
because I'm not doing it in each country
but I can now do it across the board for
every rated country so if your default
spread is 2% let's play it out 2% * 1.35
is
2.7% I add the 2.7% to the
4.33% I come up with an equity risk
premium of
7.03% there are 145 rated countries and
now have a pathway to get the equity
risk premium for each of those 145
countries saying what if a country is
not R we'll come to that but I have the
bulk of the world covered now in terms
of equity risk premiums so let's cut
past the abstractions let's see what the
world looks like in terms of equity risk
premiums at the start of 2025 let's pick
Latin America I mean all too often we
think of Latin America as a region but
it's a wildly diverse region terms of
equity risk premiums the safest country
in Latin America is Chile you can see in
terms of risk premium A2 rating
1.13% country risk BR so basically I
looked up the default spread for an A2
rating multiply by 1.35 I come up with
1.13% I get a total risk premium of
5.46% I do this for every Latin American
country the riskiest country in Latin
America no surprises Venezuela the
equity risk premium in Venezuela is
27.5% think about the equation risk free
rate plus beta times risk premium if you
have an equity risk premum of 27 and a
half per. what's your cost of equity
going to look like for an average risk
stock even in dollar terms 30%
35% welcome to risky countries your
Equity risk is going to shoot doesn't
mean you want to invest in Venezuela but
you will have to make much higher
returns to break even so as you look
across Latin America you see the very
I also computed an equity risk for Latin
America as a
region by taking a weighted average of
the equity risk premiums of each of the
countries he's saying weighted by what
by their GDP Brazil should matter more
than Honduras when you think about Latin
America's a region because it's half the
population of Latin America right there
so when you look at that weighted
average it reflects what I think the
equator sueme of the region is so as you
go through I've pretty much as I said
covered the world this is the most
downloaded data set on my website by
far it gets downloaded Us in the
strangest places I've lost all control
of how it's used I just let it right I
mean I you know I can track who's coming
on my on my web page to download stuff
sometimes geographically and the usual
culprits are the English-speaking
countries us Australia India always pops
up there but one month I check in
Lithuania is on top of the list my first
question is how many people are there in
Lithuania why are they all coming to my
web page it turned out that that month
the Lithuanian privatization authorities
had required people to use My Equity
risk premiums to Value their
privatizations I had nothing to do with
it but once in a while I will get an
email from somebody using the data and
I'm not sure how to
respond I get an email from the New
Zealand milk board I didn't even know
there was a milk board in New Zealand
till I get this email saying we're using
your Equity risk premiums to set milk
prices for
farmers who you selling the milk to
Zimbabwe but usually the question is how
do you come up with it it's not rocket
science they say look I'm not doing deep
country analysis this is how I come up
with the
number but once in a while an email will
go over the top and I just let it ride I
remember getting an email from a Libyan
business person
long 10 years ago this is how the email
begins you have destroyed Lebanon I'm
sorry Lebanon Lebanese business person
you've destroyed Lebanon I said what I
destroyed Lebanon you've had 30 years of
Civil War in Hezbollah and I'm the guy
who did it what exactly did I do and
turned out that this Lebanese business
person was valuing his business for a
sale and hired an appraiser and the
appraiser used the equity risk premium
for Lebanon from my web page and I mean
if you look at Lebanon it's like 27.9
wasn't that bad it was like 15 or 15%
and when you use a 15% Equity risk
premium and you put it into your cost of
equity and the cost of capital you get a
high discount rate and a low value this
guy felt he'd been jipped and was all my
fault I as I said I wasn't sure how to
respond so I told him what the truth was
I'm it's not it wasn't me it was Moody
because ultimately if you look at what's
driving those Equity risk premiums it's
not my assessing the country it starts
with a bad rating you're going to go
with that bad rating to end up with a
high Equity risk PR so if you're from a
country that I've assigned a high Equity
risk I'm my deepest apologies to you but
it's really not my fault it's Moody's
fault so if you don't like the big
Equity risk premium for Jamaica take it
up with Moody's and maybe tell them that
you deserve a higher rating it's
entirely rating
driven one final point if you look at
the top right hand corner you see that
black box take a look at the countries
in that back black box you got Algeria
brune Gambia G so North Korea you got
Syria these are called Frontier markets
what are Frontier markets these are
countries which don't have a rating why
do they not have a rating let's play it
out let's suppose you get hired by SNP
or moodies your first day at work you're
told we've given you country to assess
you're very excited first day at work so
where am I going North
Korea my guess is you won't stay very
long at that job because you go to North
Korea you might not come back so there's
a reason these countries are not rated
they're in parts of the world where
basically people have given up for the
longest time they weren't on my
list until I get an email from a Syrian
business person must have been the last
business person left in
Syria he said I'm trying to estimate a
hurdled rate for my company and I cannot
find an equity risk
premium for Syria why very accusatory
tone I said you don't have a rating I
can't give you an equity risk premium he
said what am I supposed to
do my Rea I was going to tell him what I
honestly thought he should do is maybe
get the heck out of there and email me
from somebody somewhere else but I said
you have a point and I'm going to try to
estimate an equity risk bre for Ser so I
started estimating Equity risk breams
for Frontier markets by
effectively adopting it's another
version of cheating there's no rating
for Syria or North Korea but there are
these services that measure country risk
with scores Economist does it I use a
service called political Risk Service
I've used a long time they're all pretty
much the same thing the World Bank does
it they attach a country risk core where
they bring in all the things that they
think about in that country that should
go into risk political risk Services has
risks scores for each of these countries
so let's take a country let's say let's
take Syria risk score is 46.5 the lower
the score the riskier
country highest risk score country the
safest country I think was Switzerland
but Syria was
46.5 I went looking for other countries
that PRS rates which had scores between
45 and 50 and I found five countries and
you can see where I'm going to go next
right three of them had ratings and an
equity risk premium I took those numbers
and I average them out and I attached to
Syria simplistic guilty as charged but
if you can find a better way to assess
Equity risk premium for North Korea I'd
love to hear it but at least for the
moment I have a placeholder so if you're
a company that gets half your revenues
in Syria and half in North Korea God
help you as a company but I can give you
an equity risk PR it's going to be huge
you're going to complain about it but
why would you expect something different
when you're operating in the riskiest
parts of the world so I update this
twice every year once at the start of
the year once I will update again July
1st can things happen in the inter
absolutely now I remember doing this I
think a few years ago Sri Lanka had this
really decent rating really know and
Equity risk PR that reflected and within
the next six-month period there had been
a coup the P the president had fled the
country and the equity risk shot through
the roof so there will be times when
these Equity risk PRS get dated
hopefully none of you analyzing a
company in a country where that'll
happen before May 5th if it does we'll
talk about how to update it but these
are the equity rprs to the
world as I said I need this when I look
at companies and to see why when you
look at a company the place you often
think about is the place of
incorporation think of Brazilian
companies Indian companies us
companies and that might have been okay
40 years ago the place you were
Incorporated often was the country in
which you you operated as well but if
you look at today's world the way I
describ you we're surrounded by
multinationals that through the accident
of History happen to be incorporated and
traded in some part of the world my son
works at Disney the headquarters is in
are in Burbank it's a US company but in
2013 when I looked at Disney they broke
their revenues down by region now do you
see why I computed the weighted average
by region because many companies don't
break it down by country there are too
many countries Coca-Cola there'll be 72
countries they break it down by region
so there are four regions they give you
the percentage of revenues you're saying
why did you use revenues it's the only
thing they broke down by region Beggars
can't be choosers I'd rather use
operating income you might want to use
something else but this is the one thing
that companies routinely break down so
there's the breakdown of revenues that
has actually shifted even more away from
the US since 20 but in 2013 80 2% of
Disney's revenues came from the US about
12% from Europe about 6% from Asia and
less than 1% of Latin America today the
Asia portion is about three times higher
than it was in
2013 but 2013 that's what the revenues
look like there are the equity risk
premiums by region in 2013 so don't look
at the 2024 numbers the 2013 numbers the
equity risk premium I would use for
Disney as a company is 5 .
76% this is going to come into play
Because when we get into the project
analysis section we're going to look at
a Disney theme park in Rio this
hypothetical theme park and I'm going to
ask you what the hurdle rate for the
theme park should be and guess what
you're going to look at you're not going
to look at the equity risk premum for
Disney as a company you're going to look
at the equity risk premium of the part
of the world that that project opens up
in so that's the reason you need the
entire world in front of you because if
you're looking at as a global company at
where to build your next Factory where
you're directing your next Revenue this
will affect whether you make that
judgment in the first
place and if you look at the rest of my
companies here's what they look like
bookscape was easy privately owned
bookstore in New York City 100% of the
revenues in the US I just used the US
Equity risk premium Val is a Brazilian
company in terms of incorporation but
take a look at the part of the world
where they get the most
revenues it's China
right Val is a multinational so when I
look at the equity risk premium for Val
it should reflect where they get the
revenues Motors again Indian
company in terms of incorporation but
China was very close to India in at the
time that I did this in 2013 now China
is actually a bigger market for T Motors
than India is mostly because of the
Jaguar Land Rover exposure in
China B do 100% in China I don't I've
never talk to somebody who's used the
Buu search engine who's not lived in
China so maybe one day it'll be
elsewhere but for the moment 100% in
China and finally deutche Bank you know
it's a Germany nor so basically you can
see the spread again the point I'm
trying to make is don't look at where a
company is incorporated look at where it
does business Tata consulting services
might be an Indian company but I compute
the equity risk premium for Tata
consulting services it gets 8% of its
revenues in India it gets 92% in the
rest of the world now part of the push
back might be why revenues as I said
part of the reason for that is the
information on breakdown geographically
is often just on revenues but what if
your company gives Abid by
region or operating income by region can
you use them instead I tend not to and
I'll tell you why when you see operating
income by region somebody's estimating
the operating income usually an
accountant right how do how do you
decide what the operating income is you
take the revenues by region which you
know and then you take expenses by
region but if you're a big company you
also have these big expenses that are
corporate they get allocated across the
region somebody's making that allocation
judgment so when you look at things like
operating income I'm a little suspicious
about whether I'm getting operating
exposure or where your taxes are lowest
okay maybe that's what's causing the
allocation so the reason I stay with
revenues is it's always there
it's it's less subject to accounting
manipulation and it can never be
negative and that's a big deal right
because if you have a negative number in
the mix the weights basically get thrown
off I don't know why that pages in
there so the the implied Equity risk
premium that drives these numbers is a
4.33% so when I talk about implied
Equity risk premiums last session I
showed you the implied Equity risk
premium at the start of
2025 can you use it all the way through
this project for the moment yes because
implied Equity risk PRS haven't changed
that much but if there is a crisis
you're going to see the implied Equity
risk premium go into motion my
definition of a crisis the price of risk
changes pretty dramatically over a short
period this is the 2008
crisis okay September 12th of
2008 so
Friday I remember I left work early why
because I always leave work early so
Friday I don't even know why I come into
work in the first place I no longer do
actually but those days I'd come into to
work and I left work early and you know
on the train and I'm reading the news
and there's a news
story that LeMans is in trouble but that
negotiating with bar Clays to be bought
out over the weekend I'll be quite
honest the news story right this is a
interesting news story it's a big news
story for New York but this isn't going
to move
markets and of course you wake up on
Monday and you have the start of that
financial crisis You' have meltdown day
by day through that crisis I estimated
the implied Equity risk premium and
that's the advantage of an implied
premium is you can do it on a daily
basis the index moves you do it you can
do it within the
day and if you look at what happened to
implied Equity risk premium it started
at about four so the green line is
implied premium started about 4 and a
half% on September 12th there was a day
in November where that implied premium
was almost 8% how did that play out
there was a market collapse when implied
premiums go up quickly the price of the
index has to collapse because earnings
and cash flows can't keep
up that 8% by the end of the year it
settled into
6.43% so can implied premiums change
over a short period they can if there's
a crisis and the price of risk changes
dramatically that premium did not get
back to pre2 2008 levels for almost six
years because you left there's trauma
aftere after crisis you get a more more
risk averse premium statement in
contrast here's September here's
2020 there's February 14th of 2020
that's the first news story we get about
covid kind of breaking out of cruise
ships in China and we're saying this is
a global pandemic
between February 14th and March 20th the
implied Equity risk premium went from
about again about four 4 and a half% to
again about
8% that was the February 14th through
March 23rd was when the S&P 500 lost 35%
of its value Global meltdown why because
people were
scared wasn't it wasn't just the economy
shutting down nobody had any idea what
was coming and many of you remember
right I mean you might have not been in
business or markets but remember those
months where you you had no idea whether
the shutdown how long would last when
will it open up when it opens up what
will happen in hindsight we claimed to
know but at that time we did not what
was different about
2020 is how quickly the market changed
its
mind on March 23rd 2020 it was it was
the end game people were convinced that
this meltdown would not know basically
the stocks would never come back and
experts said this is going to be trauma
we're going to take years to but by
September the market was back to where
it was before the
crisis so one of the advantages of
implied premiums is everything can
change quickly and you can track it and
you doing country risk premiums because
it becomes the base number you're
basically going to see Equity risk
premiums rise very quickly across the
board for all countries because that
base number has gone up
so let's talk about the start of 2025
what the world looks like in terms of
implied premiums so I showed you the
November 2013 number you see what
happens in a crisis started 2025 the S&P
500 was at
5,881
okay got my expected cash flows for the
next 5 years using exactly the same
process I used in November of 2013 get
the trailing 12mon data and then project
out based on analyst growth rates what
those cash flows will be in year 1 year
2 year three year four year five Beyond
year five cash flows continue to grow
now at a risk free rate of 4.58% because
that's what the risk rate rate had
become exactly the same process I Sol
for an expected return and at the start
at 2025 based on what people were paying
for US
Stocks the implied the the expected
return on stocks was 8.91% you subtract
out the risk free rate of
4.58% the implied premium you come up
with is 4.33% that was the base number
that you saw when I computed all of the
country risk
premiums so as you go through 2025
you're going to see that number kind of
shift and here again there's a
Divergence between What markets are
saying and what
macroeconomists are saying right because
macroeconomist are saying we in
terrifying times changes coming tariffs
and taxes and crazy things are happening
but markets at least for the moment seem
to diverge from experts and I'm going to
hold my judgment cuz every time experts
and markets have disagreed in the last
four
years I've looked back and said I wish I
trusted markets right because it turns
out that at least in the aggregate
Market seem to get it more correct than
experts to so at the moment that's what
you're looking at in fact if you look at
the 58.81 you know what that number
looks like today and what's the S&P 500
it had a new high yesterday I think 60
100 maybe so the index has gone up I'm
going to ask a pure math question
assuming the cash flows haven't changed
dramatically if the index goes
up what should happen to your expected
return go down or go
up you pay more UPF front think bonds
and interest rates right you pay more
for a bond what do you do to the
interest rate you ear on the bond it
goes down same phenomenon kicks in index
goes up the equity the expected return
comes down the t- bond rate is now down
to about 4.47% from 4.58% slightly lower
t- bond rate the index is gone up so
slightly lower expected return the
equity risk premium is pretty much
stayed around
4.3% but as I said could change in the
dot September 12th 2008 everything
looked fine until two days later you
woke up and said it's not that fine so
this can change dramatically now I'm not
wishing a crisis on you but if a crisis
does come you have a mechanism for
saying I'm going to adjust my cost of
equity and cost of capital because what
I estimated a week ago is no longer
appropriate one final graph before we
leave these implied Equity risk PRS
discussions behind us I've been graphing
this implied Equity risk premium going
back to 1960 obviously I didn't start
doing it in 1960 I'd have been too young
to start implied premiums
then but I've put so the way I estimate
the implied premium 19 60s I assume I
know nothing about what happens after
1960 I put myself down January 1st 1960
based on what I knew and I compute the
implied Equity risk pram start of every
year and you can see the the graph tells
you the history of US equities for the
last 60 years in the
1960s implied Equity risk BRS the US
were between three and three and a half%
and they were very stable the US was the
center of the global economic Universe
it was the most mean converting
predictable Market of all
time and by 1970 people said not what
can happen in the US where a mature
Market we are the global market and then
you get to the 1970s clearly something
is changing the implied premium is
rising so remind me again premiums go up
what's happening to stock pric in the
70s they're going
down right what was triggering the
increase in premiums in the
1970s oil shock triggered it but that
was a global phenomenon but in the US
oil shock
translated into higher inflation you
saying won't oil shocks always translate
into higher inflation not necessarily if
you accept lower economic growth all it
changes relative prices but here
translated to higher inflation for the
first time the US actually faced double
digit inflation and that is terrifying
for investors it act actually the
uncertainty implied premiums reflected
that in 1978 the employed Equity risk in
the US hit 6 and a half% the highest
number until then
because afterwards in 2008 in 2020 we
broke it 65% you know what the Dow was
at in
2008 it had three digits in
it it was about 800 the Dow was at 800
now it's at what 42,000 whatever it is
800 the absolute low for the market
people were convinced that stocks were
never coming back it was the end you
were loading up on real estate and gold
saying that's the place to be and then
it one of the great bull markets of all
time 1978 through 99 by the end of 1999
the implied Equity risk premium in the
US the peak of the doom boom the implied
Equity risk for the US was down to 2%
remember that survey I did last
Wednesday where asked how many of you
would buy
stocks if I offered you a 0 to 2%
premium I don't think anybody did I
think two to four somebody accepted 0 to
two no did anybody I I don't remember
did anybody put up their hand for the 0
to2 so essentially what what were you
saying 2% is too low I'm not investing
in stocks 1999 that's what the entire
Market was delivering you know what the
definition of a bubble is is when you
price things to earn 2% but then when I
ask you how much do you think you can
make on stocks you say I think I can
make 6% more than the risk free rate one
of those things has to be false and
guess what the world doesn't Bend to
your expectations you have to adjust to
a reality and that's what happened after
1999 there's a bubble bursting the
equity risk PR goes back to 4% stays
around 4% for about four years then you
have the 2008 crisis there's a spike and
since 2008 Equity risk premiums in the
US and around the world have become
higher and more volatile in fact in 2024
for the first time we saw equ risk
premum drop back to pre 2008 level so
for 16 years Equity risk premium stayed
higher
and I don't think that's a passing
phenomenon I think it reflects a reality
of globalization which is everybody's
connected to everybody else there's no
such thing as a local crisis anymore it
spills over and you're seeing that show
up in the equity
Rams so that those two pages I don't
know why they repeat so here's what I'd
like you to do right I'd like you to
take your company and break down
the
geographical in terms of geography where
the revenues come
from so break take and and look if you
and you some of you will be frustrated
when you look at that breakdown because
it might not be as good as you'd like it
to be because some companies are not
very good about the geographical areas
they might lump things together European
companies for instance break their
revenues Down based into what's called
EMA Europe Middle East and Africa is one
grouping terrible way to Bunch revenues
together because there a very different
in terms of country risk now don't don't
Rage Against the Machine yet there's no
point take what you can and computer
weighted average and move on because
that's that's what the information is
giving so take your breakdown see if you
can come up with an this all presupposes
that you've already picked a company so
if you picked a company try to come up
with an equity risk premium it's a
starting point for thinking about
country risk and how it plays out in
your cost of
capital so
let's now talk about betas we've talked
about risk free rates and the risk free
rate we said depends on the currency you
decide to do the analysis and we've
talked about Equity risk premiums and
that reflects where you do
business let talk about betas in
foundations you probably seen the
standard way in which we're all taught
to estimate B the way I was taught the
way you were probably taught is run a
regression of returns in the stock
against returns in a market index and
told the slope of the
line is the beta okay so basically when
you look at this regression the slope
measures the BET of a company and
statistically here's why bet is measure
risk beta is the measure of risk you
cannot diversify away risk coming from
the market so by running this regression
you're saying how much of the risk in my
company comes from the market
it's a terrible way to think about beta
so because it makes it into a
statistical number you run a regression
the slope of the line is the beta
incidentally in that regression there
are two other pieces of output that I'm
also going to track the first is The
Intercept right when you run a
regression there's an intercept I'm
going to argue that The Intercept of
this regression is telling you something
about how well or badly your stock has
performed During the period of the
regression it's a measure of stock
performance so you run this regression
ression for Invidia The Intercept is
going to be hugely positive because
you've had 2 years or 5 years of
incredibly good returns The Intercept is
going to measure performance and there's
also another piece of output you run you
get from any regression you run called
the r
squ statistically we know what the r squ
measures measures the proportion of
variance in your dependent variable that
is explained by your independent
variable but step back and think about
your dependent and your independent
variable here your dependent
variable is a
market when you when you think about
what what you put is your market index
whatever the index you pick in your
independent variable is the stock so the
r squ tells you how much of the variance
in the stocks is explained by the market
if that sounds even remotely familiar
when we talked about risk you can
diversify away and risk you cannot the R
square tells you what proportion the
risk in your stock you cannot diversify
away so SL the slope of the line tells
you about risk
The Intercept tells you something about
performance the R square tells you
something about where the risk in your
company is coming from so let's start
with the intercept before we go into the
bit that is the original capm that the
return on a stock is a risk-free rate
plus beta time RM minus RF that's a
standard equation for the capm I'm just
going to do a little moving around of
terms and I can restate the capm as
risk-free rate * 1 minus beta plus beta
* RM so if you if you take the capm the
traditional capm the expected return of
stock can be written as the risk-free
rate * 1 minus beta plus beta * RM the
regression we've run is returns in the
stock against returns in the market
index so compare those two equations the
slope obviously is the Beta And The
Intercept if you stocked it exactly as
the cap and predicted should be equal to
the risk free rate Time 1 minus beta so
when I run the regression I'm going to
look at The Intercept I'm going to
compare to the risk- free rate times 1
minus bet if they're roughly the say I'm
going to say your stock did roughly as
well as I thought would work given the
model if your intercept is much greater
than the risk free rate Time 1us beta
you're a winner stock you did much
better than
expected and if your risk free rate if
your intercept is less than the risk
free rate times 1 minus beta you stock
did much worse than expected and I do
this for every stock that I want to ask
a question about so you can that
difference between the intercept and the
risk free rate terms one man is is
called Jensen's Alpha and now there's a
story behind it which I think is worth
saying it's named after Michael Jensen
who in the
1960s at the University of Chicago
essentially worked on finance when it
was a very young discipline so the late
60s mik Michael decided to ask a
question which people took for granted
they knew the answer to which is do
professional money managers do better
than the
market so in
1968 Michael Jensen decided to take 125
mutual funds that's what that's how many
funds there were there so few funds that
he could just take the entire sample and
he did this Jensen's Alpha on every one
of the funds so remind me again if
professional money managers do better in
the market what should the intercept
look like when you look at their returns
should be higher than the risk-free rate
times one minut b in other words
Jensen's Alpha should be positive and he
thought that's what he was going to
find and he came back with what has
become one of the most enduring results
in finance he discovered that are the
125 funds 90 actually had negative
Jensen's alphas and collectively the
mutual funds delivered a return Jensen's
Alpha that was
negative essentially that active
investing was delivering a negative
return and that's a result that's been
replicated pretty much every single time
people have looked at it that's a topic
for a different you know we can ask why
does active investing continue to exist
if it's collectively this exercise in
futility but that's where the jenson's
alpha was born we're looking at actual
Returns versus the expected return so
you're going to run the regression you
take the intercept you compare to RF * 1
minus beta you've essentially got to
measure whether your stock and it's
purely a postmortem it's not telling you
what's going to happen in the future so
when you do this as I said for Invidia
what you're going to find out is Invidia
was a great investment over the last two
years but don't jump to the next
conclusion and say if it was a great
investment the last two years it will be
a great investment for the next two
because that part is very murky you
can't make predictions for the future
but it does give you a postm so that's a
first
stop but to do all of this though first
you've got to run a regression right and
the regression at least in every
textbook says Returns the stock againsts
Returns on the market index so let's
talk a little bit about the choices you
will have to make to run this regression
first you have to decide in an
estimation period let's take a stock
like Disney it's been publicly traded
for 70 years
I can go back all 70 if I wanted to the
date is there I can go back 10 years I
can go back five at first your first
reaction might be I want more data 70 is
better than 10 I'm going to go back 70
years but there's a catch here if you go
back 70 years you get a very different
company than the company that exists
today Disney in
1954 produced One animated movie a year
there was no Disneyland there were no
theme parks it was a small movie company
that made animated movies Disney today
is an entertainment
Colossus so the danger of going back too
far is you're going to get a very
different company think shouldn't I
should I just go to six months then well
that's the other end if you go too too
short a period you won't have enough
data most services that estimate beta is
used between two and 5 years I gave you
the little suggestion on how to pull up
the beta for your company in Bloomberg
Bloomberg's default is 2
years value line used to use five years
S&P I think uses five years so basically
it's two to five years and you can see
why people end up in that sweet spot
saying what if my company's been listed
only a year you take only what whatever
you have available if that's all you
have you're under regression over that
period so that's the first stop how far
back to go second once you decide to go
back two or five years you have to
decide how to slice up the data what
what am I talking about you take let's
say you take five years of returns you
can look at 5 years of monthly returns
which would be 60 observations 5 years
of weekly returns would be 260
observations or 5 years of daily returns
which would be
1,250 again if you're driven by the
Numbers the choice seems obvious let's
go with daily returns it'll give us more
data but daily returns are noisier
because if you don't get trading towards
the end of every day the returns won't
match up it's you know it's in fact the
daily return B is tend to all converge
around one you don't get much divver
Ence because of the noise so most
services use either weekly or monthly
returns talked about Bloomberg Bloomberg
uses two years of weekly returns 104
observations every company when you look
at that beta page you start off now the
default beta page will be two years of
weekly returns third stop you got to
estimate returns each period that should
be easy right change in price divided by
the price at the start of the period
most months and most weeks that's all
you'll be looking at what's a change in
price PR you divide by the price don't
divide by average price divide by the
price at the start of the period you're
going to get return for that week or
month with one catch which is in a few
of the periods you will get a
dividend in the US it's usually once
every three months a quarterly dividend
the Europe it could be once every six
months or even once a year don't try to
be fair and spread it out across the
weeks you if you're holding the stock in
the week in which it goes X dividend you
and only you will get the dividend
that seems like an Easy Money Maker
right why don't we just buy stocks in
the week or the day of the dividend just
collect the dividend what's a catch with
that yeah get subtracted it's not that
it gets subtracted but the price will
drop by roughly the amount of the
dividend so if you try this to make
money you will get the dividend so
that's a win but in the day that the
stock goes X dividend the stock price
will drop by roughly the amount of the
dividend so you know that's why you
don't get a whole lot of trading just
before a dividend try to collect it
because you're not going to make any
money it's just going to replace a price
appreciation with the dividend but when
you're doing returns in that that week
or that month you got to put the
dividend precisely to offset the price
effect because if you don't put it in
you're going to every three months see a
negative return on a big dividend paying
stock because you get the price drop
that month so you compute so you got
picked a period you picked an interval
you computed the returns for your stock
there's a final choice to make you have
to pick a market index right
right you know how many market indices
there are just in the US let's start
with the most commonly talked about when
people talk about the market still you
know when you hear about in which is the
index that that people tend to still
focus
on I'd love to say it's the S&P 500
still the
dow30 why because the index that's been
around the longest it's goes back almost
150 years it's a terrible index because
the 30 companies are not there's no
Rhyme or Reason for why they're there I
mean they're big companies but they're
not the 30 biggest companies but there's
a Dow 30 then there's the S&P 500
somebody tell me what you know how S&P
decides which 500 companies to include
in there what's a driving Criterion for
whether you're in the index or
not it's market cap it's a market cap
driven index there are a few other
criteria which you have multiple classes
you know if you're not there's not
enough liquidity they might cut you but
it's really the 500 largest market Gap
companies it's a market cap weighted
index of the 500 largest market cap
companies you know the S&P 500 is only
500 companies but those 500 companies
account for 85% of the market cap of all
us companies file that away so you got
the S&P 500 you got the Dow 30 you have
the NYC composite which is all of the
listed it stocks in the New York Stock
Exchange but increasingly it's getting
disconnected from the market
why take a look at the seven biggest
companies in the market right seven
they're all in the NASDAQ they've stayed
the old days it used to be that when you
got to be a bigger company you
transition from the NASDAQ to the NYC
that's no longer the case so you you
have the NYC
composite and then you have the NASDAQ
index which is really a tech index you
can't call it a market index and there
are indices like the Wilshire 5,000
which includes 5,000 companies and you
have all these choices on a Bloomberg on
the Bloomberg there's a default index
but you can change the index to any one
of those other indices or you can even
pick a sector index there are tech
company indices and pharmaceutical
company indices so before we make that
choice I want you to think about what
should go into picking the best index to
get a beta
for all of this is in service of what
model the capital asset pricing model
right you remember what we all ended up
holding in a capm
world we all ended up holding the market
portfolio because we had no trading cost
and no information cost and no way of
telling which stocks achieve what was in
that market portfolio every single
traded asset in the world held in
proportion to its market value so we can
start already knocking off
indices can I run a regression against
the Dow 30 I can but be pointless it's a
terrible index why there are only 30
companies even the S&P 500 is only 500
companies but it's saving races their
market cap weighted and it's 85% of the
index so if you had to pick an index S&P
500 wins out of the dow30 it wins out of
the NYC composite it wins out over the
NASDAQ an index like the Wilshire 5000
might look like a better index but it
doesn't have people don't trust it
enough it doesn't have the kind of
History you can already see why almost
by default if you look at beta services
in the US the index you would see
getting used to get a beta for a company
is the S&P
500 but before we leave this though was
there anything in the capm that said
only domestic stocks in a market index
said trated assets right could be Global
I wanted to hold that thought because if
we're estimating betas for companies in
a world with global Traders should we
even be running these in regressions
against domestic IND which is what we
traditionally see done or should we be
looking at something that is a global
index and estimating bait is against a
global index no service does that right
now but we can talk about maybe that's
where we should be moving towards but
for the moment you see domestic indices
for the US you'll see the S&P 500 so I
want to run an aggression of Disney
against the S&P 500 and I have to make
choices how far back to go and what
interval to use so in 2013 when I when I
did this here are the choices are made I
use five years my if I want a a good
beta estimate my preference is 5 years
over two years because I prefer to use
monthly data monthly data is better than
than weekly weekly is better than daily
and once you go monthly you can't go
with just two years because you only 24
observations I'm almost trapped by my
choice of return interval to go back
longer so 5 years of monthly returns and
I'm going to stick with what every
service is using the has and pay 500 and
every month so initially when I did this
I did this on Excel spreadsheet every
month I collected the Disney price at
the start of the month and Disney price
at the end of the month so if you like
take December of 2009 the stock went
from
$302 to
$32.25 it went up by $223 cents in that
month it was a good month for Disney and
during that month which happened to be
an next dividend month there was also 35
Cent dividend so to compute the return I
take the change in price I add the
dividend and I divide by the price at
the start of the month I end up with a
return for Disney of
7.88% in December of 20 2009 and I do
this for every month for 60 months
sounds like it's lot of work but in
Excel spreadsheet just copying that
equation done so now I have with 60
months of data 59 months of returns do
you see why I lose one month to get the
return I need the change in price so the
first month so I have 59 months of data
now I turn to the index and I do exactly
the same thing I take the index at the
start of the month index at the end of
the month I take the change but with the
index there is a little bit of a problem
because the index is composed of 500
companies some of which pay dividend
some of which don't so collectively
there's a dividend on the index as well
you don't see that when you track the
index but there is a dividend and you
can see what that dividend is you go to
Bloomberg they report the the dividends
per month in 2000 in December 2009 that
dividend on the index was 1. 1683 and I
do exactly what I did for Disney for the
S&P 5 take the change in Price Plus the
dividend divided by the index at the
start of the month I end up with the
return for Disney in December of 2009
the market was up
1.8% but Disney was up 7.9% why
something good happened to Disney maybe
a movie did better than
expected and I did this for every month
and when I was done I had 59 months of
returns for Disney and 59 months of
returns for the S&P 500
now before we had regression packages
you had to run a regression by hand the
first thing you did was you created what
was called a scatter plot in a scatter
plot here's what you do you take each
month of data and you look at what the
return on the stock was and the return
on the index and you plot that so there
should be
59 points if you want to count each
month
has and then you fit a regression line
that sounds like a weird thing to say
but how do you come up with this best f
fit
line you remember in statistics how in a
regression we fit this this line through
the points what's the Criterion we use
fact the way regression is described in
statistics who kind of gives it
away you minimize the square distance
from the line the original Greek version
of a regression people actually measure
the distance so there a lot more work
than running it through your mini tab or
SPSS or whatever your package is they
took the distance they squared the
distance I want to minimize the squared
distance from the line so trust me on
this one this line that I fit through is
the best fit line if you don't believe
me come up with the ruler take the
distance Square it see if you can
minimize but that is the
criteria of course with the regression
packages it does it for you it finds the
best fit line and if you have a
regression package it vomits out the
output from the regression right it
gives you the intercept the slope
the r squ but then it also reports the
standard errors on each of those numbers
telling the world look there's a number
but this is what you have to watch out
for so let's look at what the output
from this regression was first The
Intercept was
071 what does that tell you for the
moment it's a good news that it's
positive if a negative already in a hole
and you start digging it's positive how
positive we have to compare it still to
the risk free rate * 1 minus beta the
slope was 1.25
the two extra decimals is kind of
Overkill what does that tell me to the
extent that I trust this regression the
beta for the company is
1.25 you're saying what's this 0.1 below
that's a standard error in the estimate
so I have a regression number 1.25 but
I'm saying look you know it's it's an
estimate I could be wrong here's how
wrong I can be and finally the R square
of the regression was about
73% 73% of the variance in Disney stock
can be explained by the market or put
differently 27% of variance in Disney
stock is company completely coming from
the company so when you think about
diversification you can't do much about
the 73% but you can take away the
27% so let's take this regression output
and see what we can extract from it
about Disney as a company one of the
good way good things to do at the start
of looking at a company is to get
acquainted with your company know what
kind of company is it being a good
company a Bad Company how is it done
running the regression gets you started
in the
process so let's start with the
intercept The Intercept was 71% so
0.71 in decimals is 71% so The Intercept
is
71% I need to compare to the risk-free
rate Time 1 minus beta my returns are
all monthly returns so my risk free rate
has to be a monthly risk free rate so if
you look at the monthly risk free rate
rate there between 2008 and 13 was
.5% that's an annualized rate so to make
it monthly I've got to divide by 12 so
I've got a risk free rate very close to
0.04% so that's my risk free rate
multiplied by my Beta gives me a risk
free rate Time 1 minus bait of minus
.01% what does it even tell me if Disney
had done exactly as predicted by the
capm during this period The Intercept I
should have come up with should have
been minus .01%
I actually came up with
71% you take the difference between
those two numbers 72% that's how much
dis needed better than expected on a
monthly basis doesn't sound like much
right 72% but that's per month if you
annualize that number by raising it to
the^ 12 the return I come up with is
9.02% on an annual basis between 2008
and 2013 Disney delivered 9.02% more
more than expected we give a very simple
way to get a grasp on what a Jensen's
Alpha is let's assume that you have a
stock with a beta
1.5 let's say the market is up 20% let's
say the risk free rate is close to
zero if you have market up 20% you bait
at 1.5 how much should your stock be up
about 30% right when you have a Jensen
Al of 9% you deliver the 30% plus 9% so
it's over and above the expected
return Jensen alfas basically as I said
are a postmodem all it's telling is
between 2008 and 2013 Disney did really
well it delivered more than expected
then you can dig deeper what did it do
to do better than expected maybe it did
a it bought Pixar sometime to the period
it bought know Star Wars during that
period maybe that's what's pushing up
the returns but you look for an
underlying Source not just number it's
telling me something about the
company so let's assume you do this for
every single traded stock in the market
mechanically it sounds like a lot of
work but it's it's the same process for
every company take starting with a
working through Z you compute the
Jensen's Alpha for every
stock so you got 2,000 stocks you got
the Jensen's Alpha for every stock what
should the average Jensen's Alpha be
across all stocks
does it matter whether the stock market
was up or down or let's say the market
was strongly up should the Jensen's
Alpha therefore be a big positive number
remind me again what Jensen's Alpha
measures it measures what your stock did
after correcting for what the market did
and the risk of the stock right can
stocks collectively beat themselves
obviously
not the average ense Alpha across all
stocks really a weighted average ense
Alpha should be roughly zero
so what I'm preparing you for is when
you compute the Jensen's Alpha for your
stock and you get
.1% part of you is going to say that's
not very much my stock didn't do very
well the fact that you have a plus in
front of your Jensen Alpha is already a
win because half of all stocks will have
negative Jensen alphas and you said
thank God my stock is not one of those
Jensen Alphas you compare to zero
because the average across all stocks is
zero and if you use that then clearly
Disney had a good 5year period Sensen
Alpha was 9% so I want one followup
question during this period Bob Aro was
was Disney CEO he came in after you know
Michael Eisner he's clearly
done incredible job right 9.0 should I
therefore give him a big bonus because
the Jensen Al is positive or do I need
to stop and check something else before
I start rewarding management for having
positive Jensen Alphas of firing
management because they had negative
gensen Alphas what's the last stop I
have to make
y it's possible that entertainment
companies collectively had a good 5e
period you know the best way to think of
this is oil companies
right if you take any fiveyear period
for oil companies you either get really
big positive Jensen alas really big
negative Jensen alas what drives it what
oil prices did the top management did
nothing to do with that so the one point
I would emphasize is if you do find for
your company that a big positive alas
it's not a sign necessarily that the
that the management is doing a great job
they might just have been in the right
place at the right time conversely if
your company is a big negative Jensen's
Alpha before dumping on your management
you might want to step back and say well
is this something that was sector-wide
that they really could not avoid on my
web page I have average Jensen's Alphas
by Industry Group and the reason I have
that there is when I compute the alpha
for a company I want to compare to the
industry and say am I capturing
something that was industrywide or
something that is specific to the
company so any questions about Jensen's
Alpha you're an investor then what's the
essence of successful investing what are
you trying to
find if if you think in terms of
Jensen's
Alphas your
portfolio should be composed of
companies that will have not positive
Jensen Alphas in the past but will have
positive gensen Alphas in the future
that's why in inv in you have this thing
called Alpha that portfolio manes talk
about all the time what's your alpha
alpha basically is that excess return
it's their version looking forward of
I'm a good stock picker and if I'm a
good stock picker I should be able to
find companies that are more likely to
have positive gensen Alphas then NE and
that's what Michael Jensen discovered
did not work in active investing but
maybe you're the special one you can do
this better than those investors
SC now when you look at Invidia Jensen
Al is anybody doing Nidia for their
project for the
project nobody is really I have thought
a lot of people have gathered around
successful
company you can already see even without
doing the math what do you think the
Jensen s is going to look like for
Nidia it's going to be like
150% and while you look at the 150% and
regret not buying Nvidia 2 years ago
which we tend to do right we look at a
great stock I wish i' bought paler a
year ago I wish I I don't own pal I wish
I the reason I don't want to spend too
much time there is for every stock like
Invidia with the 200% Jensen's Alpha
there has to be a stock at the other
side which is like a m it can't be minus
200 100% obviously with the so as you
regret not buying inedia you should also
probably stop and say thank you God for
not letting me buy that stock with a
minus 95% jens's Alpha life is too short
for regrets here so when you computer
Gents Alpha for a stock it might not
tell you much about what you can make as
an investor because it's too
late but it's also not worth looking
back and saying I wish I bought the
stock two years ago because that's not
going to get you very far so Jensen's
Alpha is measure performance they
measure past performance not necessarily
future performance and across all stocks
the average ense Alpha is going to be
zero so all you looking for is can you
beat
zero let's talk talk about the slope of
the regression slope of the B regression
here was 1.25 but I did give you a
standard eror of 0.10 let's see if you
can remember enough statistics to fill
in the details here right so you got a
slope of 1.25 standard Arrow 0.10 if I
ask you for a point estimate one number
what do we train in statistics to give
us that one
number it's going to give the
1.25 and most Services stop right there
but if you are in a statistics class and
I pushed you and said that's your point
estimate one number but can you give me
a range with 67% confidence which is not
a great deal of confidence you're going
to be wrong onethird of the time what's
the significance of the 67% in terms of
statistics it's one standard deviation
on either side the coefficients from
regressions are normally distributed so
if you have a
1.25 beta in a 0.1 standard error the
true beta can be anywhere from 1 .5 to
1.35 everybody clear what I so if I ask
you for 95% confidence that's two
standard errors it's 1.05 to one and you
you can play it out 99% confidence
becomes three standard errors the point
I'm trying to make is a regression
doesn't tell you what the beta is it
gives you a range on the
beta you're saying is 0.1 a big standard
error by us company standards it's a
small standard error the median standard
error for a beta estimate in the US is
closer to
0.25 next time you see a service beta
for a company a 1.1 or 1.5 remember
there's a range around it it's a typical
us company that range can be a pretty
wide one and already you can see why
trusting a regression beta as the right
beta for your company is already a
dangerous place to be because it comes
with this big range around
it last piece of output from the
regression was the r squ
73% at regression if if I trust the
regression 73% of the risk in Disney
comes from the market from inflation
interest rates big macroeconomic forces
27% is company's specific so how well
the Avengers movie does isn't the
27% but where the people come to the
theme park because exchange rates change
could be in the
73% and if you trust the capm it's the
73 % that you're going to get rewarded
for so you don't even have to trust the
cap if you're Diversified it's only the
73% that matters right but that now just
as a an as side I've been Computing
these R squares for us companies for a
while and since 2008 the average r
squared for us companies has gone from
about 30% to about so the across the
board there's been an increase in our
Square what does it tell you about
markets and economies when you you see
the r squar for an entire Market
especially one as big as the
US go from 30% to
50% and I gave you kind of a clue 2008
what is you know what what what what do
you think 2008 brought to the table
that's changed markets I think
effectively
forever macro risk has become a much
there was a time in the US where you
were told especially oldtime value
investors just pick a good company
that's all all that matters you're going
to make money in the long term and in
the 20th century us that was absolutely
true because the economy didn't do crazy
things you didn't get major shocks to
the economy you picked a good company
you were effectively rewarded that's no
longer going to be the case because post
2008 you could pick a good company and
then Brazil Goes to Hell in a hand
basket and your company goes down 30%
you say what
happened it is effectively a change it
it means that stock picking has been
become much more difficult because you
can no longer just look at the company
you got to think about the macro
environment you're in because that's
going to affect the return of the
investment you can complain about it as
much as you want and value investors do
but that is the facts those are the
facts you face on the ground we're a
world in which macro risk matter a lot
more than micro than they used to and
that's affecting active investing and
how you pick stock so you have players
like Kathy Wood Kathy Wood essentially
makes macro bets on Trends and says if I
get that right you know I'm going to
make money and I'm and now you can see
more of that happening as macro rist
start to push micro RIS to the
background one final Point since we're
talking about R squ now I'm going to ask
you to think like an investor and I'm
going to give you two companies and I
want you to tell me whether the r squar
from the regression let's say I've
computed both is going to affect which
company you invested so you are a
diversified investor so you could be a
mutual fund or you're just an individual
investor is Diversified and I company
with two companies Disney and amen let's
say they both have the same beta
1.25 but Disney's R squ is 73% but
ament's R squ is only 25% why because
it's a farmer company a lot of the risk
are drug specific they have nothing to
do with the market but my question is is
one of choice let's say you can pick
only one of these two stocks they have
the same beta but very different R
squads so here are the three choice
you'd pick Amgen because it has a lower
R squ Disney because it is a higher r
squ or you wouldn't care so with how
many of you would pick amen because it
has a lower r squar or less of its risk
that's Market risk BR you look like you
might pick it okay and what would your
rationale
be but remember you're diversify the
only risk that you'll feel is the risk
that you cannot diversify and guess what
measures that the bait already measured
it right so the fact that the r squ is
different R squ just tells you the
proportion of the risk that comes from
Market B it actually tells you the units
of risk you face right so as a
diversified investor you could probably
going say I don't care because the
portion that's not Market is going to
get Diversified away
anyway so diversifi excuse me
Diversified investors should not care
what the r squ is but let's say that the
investor is your eccentric uncle
he doesn't trust mutual funds he buys
only five stocks why because that's his
magic number
five and he comes to you says should I
buy Disney or amjet if you have an
undiversified
investor which one should you buy the
lower squ stock or the higher Squad
stock anybody have any let's play it
through you're
undiversified you buy the low squared
stock you're buying a risky stock
right and because you're not Diversified
you're going to feel all that company
specific
risk if you're undiversified you should
go with the high R squ stock because if
you buy a low R squ stock you're going
to take risk you're not going to get
Diversified for so for God's Sak you own
five stocks don't make it Palante tier
and basically companies with low R
squares where you sit there saying big
things are happening to my company buy
companies that are maybe J Morgan with r
squ of 75% Disney with an R squ of 73%
that way you do less damage to
yourself as an investor by not being
Diversified so if you're not Diversified
you probably should tilt towards higher
R squ st most of the risk is Market risk
you're less exposed to company specific
if you're Diversified the R square
doesn't matter the risk is going to get
Diversified away
anyway now until 2001 when I taught this
class one of the requirements for the
project was you did what I did for
Disney what does it require take 59 60
months of data collect stock prices for
60 months collect the index for 60
months collect the dividends as well and
in fact doing it today is if any of you
want to do it by hand it's you can get
the data you go to yaho finance you can
get the monthly date on a stock monthly
it wasn't difficult to do but was
tedious and then the first Bloomberg
terminals arrived at start you know they
used to be down in the base in the
computer room and it was a godsent
because basically it meant that I didn't
have to ask people to run regressions
which were tedious they could go to
Bloomberg find their company which take
took a little doing if it was an obscure
company but once you found it if you
typed in the word beta you got a page
that looked like
this okay this is the regression beta
page for Bloomberg and I ran I so I got
the Bloomberg beta page for Disney from
2009 to remember that regression I ran
with an Excel spread spread sheeet I
wanted to see if I went to Bloomberg
whether I would get the same numbers
that I got from running the regression
same stock 5 years monthly data S&P 500
everything should match up right so
let's
start with looking at the output first
there's the raw beta that's a regression
beta I'll talk about the adjust beta in
a moment but the raw beta for Disney is
1.24 s remember what my Excel regression
beta was it's 1.25 to I can live with
that round it up I'm getting the same
answer so far so good The Intercept
which they called
Alpha was.
599 you know Bloomberg is very sloppy
about decimals and percentages at 0.59
is
0.99% in my regression was
71% and for the longest time this was
the Divergence that would drive me crazy
is The Intercept on Bloomberg did not
match up to The Intercept I would get
from an except
regression and finally I found out what
the reason was when I ran my regression
how did I get returns every month I took
the price change and then if there was a
dividend I included that when I did the
index I took the price change and then I
added the monthly dividend Bloomberg
runs its regressions entirely with price
changes why because it's easier for the
computer you don't have every third
month you don't have to deal with it and
their reaction be most people come to
the space to get the beta you're getting
roughly the same beta why are you
complaining about the intercept nobody
uses it anyway I do so I want to run it
right so I do think dividend should be
part of the equation so if you're
getting an intercept that's different
from running a regression by hand that's
part of the reason the r squ
73% pretty much where I was it third
decimal was off so the bit and the r squ
are pretty close and will that always be
the case if you have a non-dividend or a
low dividend paying stock it'll probably
be very similar to Disney ba and R but
if you have a big dividend paying
company you're doing a beta for a real
estate investment trust or maybe a bank
which pays a big dividend your Bloomberg
bait is already off because a big chunk
of your Returns come from dividends and
the regression is being run without
those
dividence so by all means use the
Bloomberg beta page but remember if you
have a big dividend paying company that
beta might be skewed and if you really
want to see what the beta looks like you
really have to go to Yo Finance download
the price and run it for yourself one
final Point you're saying what's the
adjusted
beta sounds fancy right
adjusted now the old days they actually
used to tell you what the adjust beta
was I'm going to give it give you how
Bloomberg comput adjust beta not just
for Disney but for every stock that they
track so when you pulled up the beta for
your company here's how the adjust beta
is going to be computed and if you don't
believe me test it out it's 67 * the raw
beta plus 33 3 * 1 you're saying what if
your regression beta is 1.8 your
adjusted beta will become
1.53 if your regression beta is 1.5 your
adjust beta will become
1.33 if your regression beta is 1.2
it'll become 1.13 and if your regression
beta is 6 your adjusted beta will become
73 notice the trend here what what are
they doing to every regression
beta by using this
adjustment 1.8 became 1.53 1.5 became
1.33 1.2 became 1.13 and 6 became
73 they're pushing the beta towards one
what's so magical about one the average
beta for the market they're trying to be
helpful they're saying over time your
company will probably get bigger it'll
probably look more like the market the
beta will start to move towards one to
which your reaction should be please
stop helping cuz those 67 and33 weights
are the weights they use for every sing
single one of the 40,000 companies they
computer adjusted baers for they're like
magic
weights so the first time I encountered
this I was curious where do you come up
at the 67 and the 33 so I called
Bloomberg not the mayor but the company
and at that point it was very confusing
who you were calling maybe I should have
called the mayor as I called the company
and they put me in touch with the beta
calculation
guy there's actually a guy at Bloomberg
whose life it is to maintain a this page
imagine how exciting his life must
be he's pathetically grateful to get a
call from the outside world know what
they do maybe they keep him locked up in
a basement room feed him through a hole
in the
wall he said I'm so glad you called I
have all day to answer your questions
like five minutes to ask him questions
but he was afraid if I hung up the phone
too soon he might do something
rash so after about 10 minutes it's a
polite conversation where I complimented
him all things Bloomberg I finally asked
him the question why 67
and33 he said huh 2 minutes of silence I
can hear papers being rustled terminals
being turned off and on and finally
comes back on and says I don't know it
was here when I got
here I said when did you get here he
said 3 years ago don't blame me I said
I'm not blaming you I just want to know
where these numbers come from he says I
don't know here when I got here you know
how often that is the response you get
to numbers you use every day at work but
why do we use this 6% risk premium I
don't know it was here when I got here
when did he get here
1979 you've never stopped and asked no I
don't pick up rocks to see what's under
them so much of Finance we've Outsource
here when I got here becomes a response
and for God's sakes that should never be
the response to a number so give me a
reason I'm willing to talk about it but
here when I got here doesn't do it for
me but the biggest story here is there's
no information in the adjust there's no
adjustment in the adjusted beta all it
is is telling you which direction one is
and if you're confused about that maybe
this is not the page you should be
spending time on you have a beta 1.5 you
want to get to one you know how to get
there right go 1.4 1.3 1.2 one you don't
need somebody holding and say let me
give you a number closer to one that's
all the and every single service plays
the stupid game they run a regression
beta and then they call it predicted
beta forecasted beta adjusted beta when
all they're doing is moving the beta
towards
one so I did dig for the 67 and33 and I
found the original
Source it's a paper written in
1971 in an academic journal the Journal
of Finance where the researcher had
looked at a 100 companies through the
1960s and track the betas of every
company through the decade you saying
why only 100 companies in 1971
everything was done by hand 100
companies was about all he could handle
and here's what he found those 100
companies through the 1960s they B us
move towards one with a Stein as which
is a statistical way of saying the
waiting factor is roughly 67 and33 he
saying how did that 1971 paper end up in
the 2025 Bloom book the very first beta
estimation service was started in
Berkeley by bar Rosenberg was a profess
professor of Finance at Berkeley and
happened to be an editor of the journal
that this paper came in so bar when they
started estimating betas the way bar
Rosenberg decided how to get better
betas was he went and looked at Journal
articles and he remember that one from
three years ago he said that's a neat
idea so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to run a regression beta and then
I'm going to move it towards one using
these weights that's
1974 and it's stuck because every person
after that you know what the answer is
where did they come from I don't know
here when it when I got here it's
amazing number of things in finance get
stuck once they get started and nobody
stops and asks let's face that was
1971 the world has shifted and the
weight should be different for different
companies so what I'd like you to do
before Monday's class is pick a company
if you haven't picked it no that's First
Once you pick the company find the
Bloomberg and I gave you the locations
for a Bloomberg and in fact you know
those if you follow my my email on the
six things you need from Bloomberg it'll
take you 10 minutes you're done with the
Bloomberg for the rest of the year you
know do it while it's still you know
people are not lined up print the beta
page for your company and using that
beta page and when we start the class
we'll talk about what that tells you
about the company and how you can use
that beta page to come up with a hurdle
rate for your company okay so I'll see
you on Monday
spe
hey professor I'm Patrick Patrick I just
want to ask like for Clarity on a comedy
me earlier it was like the countryes in
a black box you said where the people
have given up like what did you mean by
that I'm sorry you said what are people
I've given up I will ask you for Clarity
on that comment the black box was it
today's CL yeah the countries you said
the countries like they don't have like
Financial dat and all well I think part
of the reason is when you have violence
in a country and there's nobody running
the country South Sudan or Syria you
can't even start the process of
assessing countri because you have no
idea who'll be running the country so
think about um more recently think about
right after Assad fell in Syria right so
now you don't even have a head of the
country country you have this new
government coming in you have no idea
what's happening you essentially give up
you say look and I have to wait for
things to settle in same thing with
Russia since 2022 there's been no rating
for Russia because the ratings agency
say we've got to wait we don't know how
this war will play out what will happen
to the sanctions so when there's that
much uncertainty even the rating cency
step back and I'm not going to try to
assess a rating when I have nothing to
go on you know the official records are
all broken I can't get to the data so
then there's no rating for the country
and people who still invest in the
country can't easily assess country risk
because there's no guidance that they
much of Africa used to be if you looked
at that map now we have Equity risk
premum for Africa there was a point in
time only four or five countries Nigeria
South Africa Egypt where you could get
ratings rest of Africa the ratings
agenes didn't even cry because they said
no it's not enough information no so I
think that when I mean raen TR basic
basally base their Sovereign ratings on
data like how much debt do you have know
what do your budget look like and if
there's no functioning government which
is often the case in in in those
Frontier markets they don't even try I
thought it sounded a bit harsh when I
first heard it but I wanted to ask you
for clarification and they want make
blackx is just a uncertainty doesn't
mean there you have that much
uncertainty there thank you thank you
for your clarification I appreciate it
take Hi how are you good there question
about the grou project um because we're
finalizing the companies and our theme
would be Hospitality okay um and I was
interested in doing Nestle in like the
thought that it could be a supplier to
hospitality that's stretching a little
bit right now okay I just want to so if
you want to make it Hospitality pick
something that is more direct pick a
small company that feeds your hospital
Nestle is such a big consumer product
company beings there might there might
be Swiss companies that feed into the
space
so
consider Source are also
to I mean if you really want to do a
Swiss company you're either going to end
up with banks or those companies right
you don't have much of a choice you know
unless you want
to don't think you can make on into
a because you want a fun swis company
pick on right shoe company kind of
breaking the mold kind of breaking in
but I think Hospital kind of constrains
you right so so so what do you have
Hotel companies you have airia trior an
airline Soo okay but okay no I mean if
it's to far F I'll go with like a more
traditional yeah something the know
there might be companies that feed into
the hotel business that are kind of
suppliers the hotel business so check to
see whe they'll probably be smaller
companies so Nestle chocolates might
shop on a on a Hotel pillow but it's
such a small percentage of their actual
revenues that that is not what's driving
them right so I'll check I mean maybe
there's some something does it have to
be Swiss can it be a com can it be a
small company that going to be another
European company I mean it can be
anything you know what one of the things
you can do is you know I gave you the
access thing for Capital IQ is you go to
Capital IQ you pick Hospitality as a
sector you you know it's one of the
sectors see what shows up pick a region
of the world Europe and say show me the
companies and then look through the list
to see if you see a name that you
recognize right yeah and say okay I'm
going to use that as
my I know there are publicly traded
companies for instance that Supply the
airlines with food yeah they're small I
know a couple of Asian companies that do
it I know that they're publicly traded
but I'm sure there are businesses that
feed off the hospitality space yeah no
no Travelocity you don't you're not
bringing expedient Trav velocity know is
Airbnb capturing that as well because
there are companies that make money off
reservations no Airbnb goes beyond that
right it's an intermediary but there are
businesses that used to be just
brokering Services right so there might
be companies that do that that are
service companies that are not hotels
they're not Airbnb but they feed off the
space or I think the airport also you
could airports are very different
businesses but there are you know
because infrastructure businesses and uh
there are few that are publicly traded
but there are companies that build
airports yeah right which are
infrastructure company that's a
specialty so you can no there's yeah
I'll check for like a more traditional
hospitality company yeah you don't have
a Reit in the hospitality space like
Marriott there's a hotel but there's
Marriott the Reit which owns just the
real estate in a hotel so basically
you're then looking at how does a
company that owns a real estate but
doesn't make any money from Hotel how do
they know fund themselves how do they
pick projects right it's a because it's
a very different business you're no
longer making any money from the hotel
you're making money from the locations
on the hotels are built so okay I'll
check it out because I think now we have
like almost just us
company pick a luxury hotel company in
Europe then which you know you have
Marriott is a hotel company but pick the
richz or the you know something which is
Europe based luxury hotel because
that'll be very different different kind
of hospitality because you'll be
catering to a niche market of very rich
people that would
be maybe there's a skiing company in
Switzerland that makes its money off the
hospitality space check to see there you
know because what else do you do in
Switzerland eat chocolate Ste
bike fondue maybe there's a fondue
company we are the the global leaders in
Fu I don't know that's than
[Music]
I think my point when you run a business
like R you face all of the problem that
business everywhere else bases times
three right you deal with and makes it
really sorry I I would hold
[Music]
back absolutely all can run that much
go
e
e e
your
phone
fore spee
spee spee
speech oh
on e
do
spe for
to
spe
spee speech speech
spee
kind of like
video
than
than for